This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Memory is the diary we all carry about with us. Oscar Wilde wrote those lines in his play, the importance of being earnest. There's something deeply comforting about this idea that memory is like a diary we can open and review. But is this really how our minds work? More than a century ago a young German philosopher named Herman Ebinghaus wanted to figure out how we retain information. He really wanted to understand memory at its most basic core.
这里是Hidden Brain，我是Shankar Vedantam。记忆是我们随身携带的日记。奥斯卡·王尔德在他的剧作《认真的重要性》中写下了这些台词。记忆就像一本我们可以随时打开查阅的日记，这种想法让人感到无比宽慰。但我们的思维真的是这样运作的吗？一个多世纪前，一位名叫赫尔曼·艾宾浩斯的年轻德国哲学家想要弄清楚我们是如何保留信息的。他非常想从最基本的层面去理解记忆。
How quickly can we learn? New information that we've never been exposed to, and how quickly does that information degrade. Psychologist Ayanna Thomas. She says Herman Ebinghaus decided to run an experiment on himself. First, he needed something to memorize. He came up with the idea of nonsense syllables. Three random letters strung together. He put them on some cards.
我们学习的速度有多快？对于我们从未接触过的新信息，这些信息衰退的速度又是怎样的？心理学家阿亚娜·托马斯说，赫尔曼·艾宾浩斯决定拿自己做实验。首先，他需要一些东西来记忆。他想出了“无意义音节”的点子。把三个随机字母连在一起，写在卡片上。
So more than 2000 of these. Then he shuffled the cards, divided them into groups, and said about learning them in a variety of controlled conditions. Sometimes he read the cards aloud. Like, move, walk, dial, send, cap, not suke. Forcing himself to read them in the exact same rate in the same soft tone of voice, keeping time to a ticking metronome. Dal sen cap, not suke, caks, leg, move.
他制作了2000多张这样的卡片。然后他洗牌、分组，并在各种受控条件下开始学习。有时他会大声朗读这些卡片。比如：move, walk, dial, send, cap, not suke。他强迫自己以完全相同的语速、相同的轻柔语调朗读，并用节拍器保持节奏。Dal sen cap, not suke, caks, leg, move。
Every time he made a mistake, he would stop, note it in his records and start over. He repeated this process periodically to see how much he could remember 20 minutes later, an hour later, nine hours, a day, and so on. Stopping, starting over, stopping, starting over for more than six months. And you might ask why would anyone want to do that? Well his motivation was he wanted to see what information was remembered, but also how much information was forgotten. This week on Hidden Brain, we bring you the latest in our annual U2.0 series
每次出错，他都会停下来，记录在案，然后重新开始。他定期重复这个过程，看看20分钟后、一小时后、九小时后、一天后等等，他能记住多少。在六个多月的时间里，他不断地停下、重来。你可能会问，为什么有人会想这样做？他的动机是想看看哪些信息被记住了，同时也想看看有多少信息被遗忘了。本周的Hidden Brain，我们将为您带来年度U2.0系列的最新内容。
as we explore the science of memory from the early ideas of Herman Ebinghaus to the latest discoveries of modern psychologists. How do our minds hold on to the events of the past? Can we ever really know for sure that our memories are telling us the truth? How we remember, why we forget, and the simple lessons we can all learn to make our memories sharp and vivid. Herman Ebbighalz remember thousands of three-letter strings and then try to see how many he remembered the same day, the next week, the next year. He discovered something that many of us experienced. Over time, he started to forget things.
我们将探索记忆科学，从赫尔曼·艾宾浩斯的早期思想一直到现代心理学家的最新发现。我们的大脑是如何留住过去事件的？我们真的能确定我们的记忆告诉我们的是真相吗？我们如何记忆，为什么遗忘，以及我们所有人都能学到的让记忆变得清晰生动的简单课程。艾宾浩斯记住了数千个三字母字符串，然后试图看看他在当天、下周、下一年能记住多少。他发现了一个我们许多人都经历过的事实：随着时间的推移，他开始遗忘。
But since he was running an experiment, it allowed him to actually measure how much he was forgetting and how quickly. It led him to discover something that is today called the forgetting curve. That forgetting curve, if you look at it, you see an exponential decline in what he can accurately remember as time passes. This again is Ayanna Thomas, a psychologist at Tufts University who studies memory. You see a really quick drop-off, so by the time you get out to a week and then a month, there's a lot of information that's been lost. But I also think what's really neat is, a month later, there's quite a bit of information that still has been retained.
但由于他在进行实验，这使他能够真正测量出他遗忘了多少以及遗忘的速度。这让他发现了今天被称为“遗忘曲线”的东西。如果你观察那条遗忘曲线，你会看到随着时间推移，他能准确记住的内容呈指数级下降。再次介绍一下塔夫茨大学研究记忆的心理学家阿亚娜·托马斯。你会看到一个非常快速的下降，所以当你到了一个星期甚至一个月的时候，很多信息已经丢失了。但我认为真正巧妙的是，一个月后，仍有相当多的信息被保留了下来。
What I find really interesting about this story, Iana, is that it reveals two things that at some level feel intuitively true to us. All of us have this experience of remembering something and then finding a week later we can't remember what we remembered. And also realizing that if we try and relearn what it is that we have forgotten, it is quicker the second time around than the first. So at one level, he is telling us things that we all experience in our life. But was he also in some ways putting on the map the idea that you can actually study these things empirically that there was a science to memory
阿亚娜，关于这个故事，我发现真正有趣的是，它揭示了两件在某种程度上让我们直觉上感到真实的事情。我们都有过这样的经历：记住了一些事情，一周后却发现记不起当时记住了什么。同时也意识到，如果我们尝试重新学习那些已经遗忘的内容，第二次会比第一次快。所以从一个层面来看，他告诉我们的是我们生活中都会经历的事情。但他在某种程度上是否也开创了“可以实证研究这些事物”的先河，即记忆是有科学可循的？
that it was amenable to to measurement and to precision? Indeed, he was the first to bring this into a laboratory where he has a hypothesis about how memory is going to operate. And he operationalizes the constructive memory. So I think about memory as a really broad, a really broad term. And that term can encompass so many different things. Right now, I'm using memory to communicate with you, right? I'm bringing things up from my long-term memory
即记忆是可以测量和精确化的？确实，他是第一个将其带入实验室的人，他提出了关于记忆如何运作的假设，并将记忆这一概念操作化了。我认为记忆是一个非常宽泛的术语，它可以涵盖许多不同的事物。现在，我正在使用记忆与你交流，对吧？我正在从我的长期记忆中提取信息。
and I'm using my working memory to communicate that information. But that's not how Ebbinghaus operationalized it. So he thinks about, okay, well, we all have this experience of learning information and forgetting information. How can I study that? And in order to study memory, what Eminghouse introduced us to was that we have to figure out what our construct is, we have to define that construct,
我正在使用我的工作记忆来传达这些信息。但这并不是艾宾浩斯对它的操作化定义。所以他思考的是，好吧，我们都有学习信息和遗忘信息的经历。我该如何研究它呢？为了研究记忆，艾宾浩斯向我们介绍的是，我们必须弄清楚我们的概念是什么，我们必须定义那个概念。
and then we have to develop tasks that are appropriate to the definition of that construct. You can think about memory in a whole host of different ways. I know how to write a bike, but I can't tell you exactly how to do it. I just know how to do it. That's still an element of memory and not the one that Abinghouse was studying. After home and Abinghouse, other researchers came along and said, okay, we can study memory systematically.
然后我们必须开发出适合该概念定义的任务。你可以用很多不同的方式来思考记忆。我知道怎么骑自行车，但我无法确切地告诉你怎么做。我只是知道怎么做。那仍然是记忆的一个要素，而不是艾宾浩斯所研究的那种。在赫尔曼·艾宾浩斯之后，其他研究人员也随之而来，他们说，好吧，我们可以系统地研究记忆。
Through careful observation and measurement, we can see how memory works and when it fails. In the 1930s, Frederick Bartlett set up an experiment that revealed a very interesting aspect of memory. The experiment revolved around a story, a Native American legend called the War of the Ghosts. One night, two young men from Egulac went down to the river to hunt seals, and while they were there, it became foggy and calm. Then they heard war cries and they thought, maybe this is a warparsie, they escaped to the shore and hid behind a log.
通过仔细的观察和测量，我们可以看到记忆是如何运作的，以及它何时会失效。20世纪30年代，弗雷德里克·巴特利特进行了一项实验，揭示了记忆的一个非常有趣的方面。实验围绕着一个故事展开，这是一个名为《幽灵之战》的美国原住民传说。一天晚上，两个来自Egulac的年轻人去河边捕海豹，当他们在那里时，天气变得有雾且平静。然后他们听到了战争的呐喊，他们想，也许这是一场战争，他们逃到岸边躲在一根圆木后面。
Now canoes came up and they heard the noise of paddles and saw one canoe coming up to them. Frederick Bartlett tested the volunteers on what they remembered of the story, sometimes hours later, sometimes days, even months and years later. And what he found was there were these systematic changes to the way these individuals were recalling. They forgot details that were foreign to them. So it was a native story about these ghosts warring during dreams. And so many of the subjects just didn't remember some of these elements that were foreign to their cultural
这时独木舟上来了，他们听到了桨的声音，看到一只独木舟向他们驶来。弗雷德里克·巴特利特测试了志愿者对故事的记忆情况，有时是在几小时后，有时是几天、几个月甚至几年后。他发现这些人的回忆方式发生了系统性的变化。他们忘记了对他们来说陌生的细节。这是一个关于这些幽灵在梦中交战的本土故事。所以许多受试者只是记不住其中一些对他们的文化理解来说陌生的元素。
understanding. Many of the subjects also made systematic changes where a word like canoe was changed to boat. And so what he found was that the subjects when they were retelling the story, they were changing the story so that it aligned with their prior experiences because those prior experiences help us generally to remember information from our autobiography. But what those prior experiences are doing is they are putting those new experiences into a just like story, where we have an idea of how things unfold,
许多受试者也做出了系统性的改变，比如把“独木舟”改成了“船”。他发现，受试者在复述故事时，会改变故事以使其与他们之前的经历保持一致，因为那些先前的经历通常有助于我们记忆自传中的信息。但这些先前的经历所做的是，它们将这些新经历放入一个“就像故事”的框架中，我们对事情如何展开有一个概念，
but we don't remember the specific details. In other words, the forgetting wasn't just random. Herman Ebinghaus had suggested that memory was like a sieve. You put stuff in and it falls out gradually over time. Frederick Bartlett said, no, there are certain things that get remembered and certain things that get forgotten. What you already know, what you're familiar with, that shapes what you remember, what you can recall, and what gets forgotten. Effectively, what the experiment showed is that when we recalled something, what we remember is only partly about the thing we are remembering.
但我们记不住具体的细节。换句话说，遗忘不仅仅是随机的。赫尔曼·艾宾浩斯曾暗示记忆就像一个筛子。你放进去东西，它会随着时间推移逐渐漏掉。弗雷德里克·巴特利特说，不，有些东西会被记住，有些东西会被遗忘。你已经知道的、你熟悉的，塑造了你记住的内容、你能回忆起的内容以及被遗忘的内容。实际上，实验表明，当我们回忆某事时，我们记住的内容只是关于我们正在记忆的事物的一部分。
Our memories are also shaped by all the other things we know. Things that are similar to what we already know are more likely to stick. Things that are less similar are likely to drop off or get modified, so they fit better with what we already remember. Memory in other words is not a simple process of opening a mental file drawer and taking things out. It involves a process of reconstruction. And I always think about it like a paleontologist, where a paleontologist
我们的记忆也受到我们所知道的其他所有事物的塑造。与我们已知事物相似的事物更有可能被记住。不太相似的事物可能会被遗漏或修改，以便更好地符合我们已经记住的内容。换句话说，记忆不是打开心理档案柜并取出东西的简单过程。它涉及一个重构的过程。我总是把它想象成古生物学家，古生物学家
uncovers a fossil, just as we have uncovered a memory. We remember a piece of an element and we have a piece of the puzzle that we start putting together with other fossil pieces that have been uncovered. And we reconstruct a, you know, from the paleontologist perspective, maybe a skeleton of a dinosaur. From our perspective, we reconstruct a memory of a past event. But that paleontologist doesn't have all of the pieces. And what that individual has to do is fill in the gaps with best guesses and prior experience, with that person's expertise on what could go there,
发掘化石，就像我们发掘记忆一样。我们记住了一个元素的一部分，我们有了拼图的一块，我们开始把它和其他被发掘出来的化石碎片拼在一起。我们重构了一个，你知道，从古生物学家的角度来看，可能是一具恐龙骨架。从我们的角度来看，我们重构了一个过去事件的记忆。但那位古生物学家并没有所有的碎片。那个人必须做的是用最好的猜测和先前的经验，用那个人对那里可能放什么东西的专业知识来填补空白。
just as we fill in the gaps of, are these memory holes with our best guess of what could go there. I mean, that is both wonderful and terrifying at the same time, I had. with our best guest of what could go there. I mean, that is both wonderful and terrifying at the same time, Ayanna. Yeah, I think it's really interesting. I think it's really interesting to think about why we do these things, why we mis-recollect our past, how those kinds of reconstruction errors occur. And I think about it in my own personal life,
就像我们用我们对那里可能放什么东西的最佳猜测来填补这些记忆漏洞一样。我的意思是，这既美妙又可怕，阿亚娜。是的，我认为这非常有趣。我认为思考我们为什么会做这些事情，为什么我们会错误地回忆过去，这些重构错误是如何发生的，是非常有趣的。我在我自己的个人生活中也会这样想。
I share my memories with my partner. And many of us who have partners, we have these sort of collaborative ways in which we recollect. But those collaborations often result in my incorporating information into my memories that were suggested by this individual, but I never experienced. And so I might have this vivid recollection of something that only my partner experienced because we've shared that information so often.
我和我的伴侣分享我的记忆。我们许多有伴侣的人，都有这种协作式的回忆方式。但这些协作往往导致我将伴侣建议的信息纳入我的记忆中，而这些信息我从未经历过。所以我可能会对只有我伴侣经历过的事情有生动的回忆，因为我们太频繁地分享这些信息了。
And so that's how we can distort memories in the laboratory. We can just get individuals who try and reconstruct events over and over again. And with each reconstructive process, they become more and more confident that that event has occurred. So I want to look at this process of mental paleontology a little more carefully, and there will be a number of experiments that have been conducted along these lines which ask people in some ways to place themselves emotionally in events and these experiments find that we change what we remember as a result of these interventions. Yes, there have been so many experiments now, I guess we're talking about 25 years worth of research.
这就是我们如何在实验室中扭曲记忆。我们可以让个人反复尝试重构事件。随着每一次重构过程，他们变得越来越确信该事件确实发生过。所以我想更仔细地审视这个“心理古生物学”的过程，已经有许多沿着这些思路进行的实验，要求人们在某种程度上在情感上将自己置于事件中，这些实验发现我们确实会因为这些干预而改变我们所记住的内容。是的，现在已经有太多的实验了，我想我们谈论的是25年的研究成果。
Looking at how people come to believe in things that never occurred. And so we see that people can come to believe that they were lost or that they took a hot air balloon ride or spilled punch on the parents of a bride at a wedding when they were young. And generally the way that these studies work is we get some sort of information about kind of events that had happened to them or had not happened to them before the age of let's say 10. And then that individual goes through
观察人们如何开始相信从未发生过的事情。我们看到人们可以开始相信他们曾经走失过，或者他们乘坐过热气球，或者在年轻时在婚礼上把潘趣酒洒在了新娘的父母身上。通常这些研究的工作方式是，我们获得一些关于他们在10岁之前发生过或未发生过的事件的信息。然后那个人经历
some sort of suggestion procedure. Researchers wanted to see if they could induce volunteers to develop false memories. In several studies, they described events to volunteers and then told them that they had drawn these accounts from conversations with their parents or siblings. Another study used a more high-tech method. on these accounts from conversations with their parents or siblings. Another study used a more high-tech method.
某种暗示程序。研究人员想看看他们是否能诱导志愿者产生虚假记忆。在几项研究中，他们向志愿者描述事件，然后告诉他们这些叙述是从与他们父母或兄弟姐妹的谈话中得来的。另一项研究使用了更高端的方法。
One of my colleagues went as far as distorting pictures using Photoshop and inserting participants into the picture of a hot air balloon. And finding that resulted in, of course, creating this whole false memory of an event that never took place. And that's quite a distinct event, right? It's taking a hot air balloon ride. Even you would think you would remember that, and if you didn't remember that, you would think you would, and that probably never happened. So the fact that this was Kim Wade and colleagues, the fact that she was able to distort individuals with this technique
我的一位同事甚至用Photoshop扭曲图片，将参与者插入到热气球的图片中。结果发现，这确实创造了一个从未发生过的事件的完整虚假记忆。那是一个相当独特的事件，对吧？乘坐热气球。即使是你也会认为你会记得，如果你不记得，你会认为你会记得，而那可能从未发生过。所以Kim Wade和同事的研究，她能够用这种技术扭曲个人记忆的事实，
really demonstrates the suggestive nature of pictures. And so personally, I have this experience when I look at old photo albums that my parents have collected, that I go back and I'll look at these old pictures of myself back and I'll look at these old pictures of myself and you know I'm a five graduating from kindergarten and I'll see these pictures and I have no memory of these events but you've had this experience we've all had this experience where you see a picture and you start to think oh yeah kind of remember that it's like you're with your wife and she's suggesting something pictures are even more distorting from that perspective because we can mentally generate
确实证明了图片的暗示性。就我个人而言，当我看着父母收集的旧相册时，我有过这种经历。我会回去看这些我自己的旧照片，比如我五岁从幼儿园毕业，我会看到这些照片，我对这些事件没有任何记忆。但你有过这种经历，我们都有过这种经历，当你看到一张照片时，你开始想，“哦，是的，我有点记得那个。”就像你和你的妻子在一起，她在暗示什么。从这个角度来看，图片更具扭曲性，因为我们可以在心理上生成
that image. And that mental generation is a big cue to us. And in some ways stories function the same way. I remember my parents telling me a story. I don't have any personal recollection of this, but it tell me a story when I was a very small child. And there was a family gathering at our home. And many people had come over.
那个图像。而那种心理生成对我们来说是一个很大的线索。在某种程度上，故事也是这样运作的。我记得我父母给我讲过一个故事。我对此没有任何个人回忆，但他们在我很小的时候给我讲过一个故事。当时我们家有一个家庭聚会。很多人都来了。
And as with many Asian households, people left their footwear at the door or at the entrance to the house before coming in. And apparently, I sort of wandered off from this gathering. And I essentially stole everyone's left shoe or left slipper and basically took all the left shoes and left slippers and basically moved them to a new location. And I have obviously no recollection whatsoever of doing this but I've heard the story so many times that to me I can actually
正如许多亚洲家庭一样，人们在进入屋子之前把鞋子留在门口或入口处。显然，我从聚会中走开了。我基本上偷走了每个人的左鞋或左拖鞋，基本上把所有的左鞋和左拖鞋都搬到了一个新的地方。我显然完全不记得做过这件事，但我听过这个故事太多次了，以至于对我来说，我实际上可以
sort of vaguely see myself doing this. And I feel also vaguely proud that even at the age of two I could pick out just the left slippers from the right ones. I think they're making that up. I don't see how a two-year-old could have really done that. I think that you might have stolen a few shoes and this story has changed so much over the years. Can you imagine? So that's very sad, Ayanna, you know, ruining one of my precious childhood memories. Well, if it really did happen, that's pretty much the thing. I'm gonna go with that version. I'm gonna go with that version. What Ayanna and other researchers have found over and over again
隐约看到自己这样做。我也感到隐约自豪，即使在两岁时，我也能从右边的拖鞋中挑出左边的。我想他们是在编造。我不认为一个两岁的孩子真的能做到这一点。我认为你可能偷了几只鞋，而这个故事多年来已经改变了很多。你能想象吗？这太令人难过了，阿亚娜，你知道，毁了我珍贵的童年记忆之一。好吧，如果它真的发生了，那基本上就是这样。我会选择那个版本。我会选择那个版本。阿亚娜和其他研究人员反复发现的是，
is that our memories are fallible. And the implications of this extend far beyond how we think about our own childhoods. They extend into serious settings like the criminal justice system where we constantly ask people to make recollections or remember things under oath. Do people remember things accurately? In the early 1970s Elizabeth Laftus and John Palmer ran an experiment to find out. What they were really interested in was how people recollect a witnessed event and how the way in which questions are phrased influenced our recollection.
我们的记忆是不可靠的。其影响远远超出了我们对自己童年的看法。它们延伸到刑事司法系统等严肃的场合，在那里我们不断要求人们在宣誓下进行回忆或记住事情。人们能准确地记住事情吗？20世纪70年代初，伊丽莎白·洛夫特斯和约翰·帕尔默进行了一项实验来找出答案。他们真正感兴趣的是人们如何回忆目击事件，以及问题的措辞方式如何影响我们的回忆。
The researchers showed their volunteers short films of car accidents. Then they asked the volunteers some questions about what they had just seen. And there was a critical manipulation in the first experiment. What they did between groups of participants was they changed one word in the question. Some people were asked how fast were the cars going when they contacted each other. Others were asked the question with a more vivid verb like how fast were the cars going when they bumped into each other, smashed into each other or hit each other. The people who heard the word smashed or collided
研究人员向志愿者展示了车祸的短片。然后他们问志愿者一些关于他们刚刚看到的内容的问题。第一个实验中有一个关键的操作。他们在参与者群体之间所做的是改变了问题中的一个词。有些人被问到“当汽车接触时速度有多快”。其他人被问到问题时使用了更生动的动词，比如“当汽车撞在一起、猛烈撞击或碰撞时速度有多快”。听到“猛烈撞击”或“碰撞”这个词的人，
recall that the cars were going faster than the people who heard the word bumped. So changing just one word in the question changed people's memory of the speed of the cars. Then there was something else, the volunteers were asked whether there was broken glass at the scene of the accident. The researchers found that volunteers were much more likely to remember seeing broken glass if the words smashed or hit had been used. And I think it's really important to note that there was no broken glass in any of the images that participants were shown in the study.
回忆起汽车的速度比听到“轻撞”这个词的人要快。所以改变问题中的一个词就改变了人们对汽车速度的记忆。然后还有另一件事，志愿者被问及事故现场是否有碎玻璃。研究人员发现，如果使用了“猛烈撞击”或“碰撞”这些词，志愿者更有可能记得看到碎玻璃。我认为非常重要的一点是，研究中向参与者展示的任何图像中都没有碎玻璃。
So not only did it change their estimates of speed, which is subjective in and of itself, but participants distorted their recollection in the act of recalling because of the word that was used. And so with no broken glass being present, participants remembered broken glass because that question was posed in a particularly suggestive way. So this has really important implications for criminal justice and how we question witnesses, how we get information about investigations from witnesses, the way in which officers at the scene of a crime, investigators during the context of interviews, the ways in which officers at the scene of a crime, investigators, during the context of interviews,
所以它不仅改变了他们对速度的估计（这本身就是主观的），而且参与者在回忆的过程中因为所使用的词汇而扭曲了他们的回忆。因此，在没有碎玻璃的情况下，参与者记住了碎玻璃，因为那个问题是以一种特别具有暗示性的方式提出的。所以这对刑事司法以及我们如何询问证人、我们如何从证人那里获取调查信息、现场警官、调查人员在访谈过程中，
the ways in which they question witnesses, whether witnesses are questioned together, whether witnesses talk to one another after the fact, and now in the age of social media, now witnesses being able to do their own online investigations. All of these elements are serving to introduce factors that can distort the recollection of witnesses. I'm wondering if it can affect jurors as well because jurors often are hearing about these stories and the media in some ways are, you know, I was taught when I was a young journalist that if you're describing a car crash, you don't say bump, you say collided because it's a more active, it's using more active language, it brings the scene to life more vividly, but something that happens routinely in the
他们询问证人的方式、证人是否被一起询问、证人在事后是否互相交谈，以及现在在社交媒体时代，证人能够进行自己的在线调查。所有这些因素都在引入可以扭曲证人回忆的因素。我想知道这是否也会影响陪审员，因为陪审员经常在媒体上听到这些故事，在某种程度上，你知道，我年轻时做记者时被教导说，如果你在描述车祸，你不要说“轻撞”，你要说“碰撞”，因为这更主动，它使用了更主动的语言，它让场景更生动地呈现出来，但这是媒体中经常发生的事情，
media of sort of dramatizing how stories work, what you're saying is that that can have the unintended effect of basically creating effectively false memories in people's heads. Indeed, and you said it in your description of using the word collided, it creates a more dramatic and vivid scene. Creating that vivid scene is what is going to be remembered. And so that post-event information, that jurors are maybe hearing or reading in the newspapers and so on and so forth, that information is what's going to be recalled as opposed to maybe their original experience
这种戏剧化故事运作方式的做法，你所说的是，这可能会产生意想不到的效果，基本上在人们脑海中创造了虚假的记忆。确实，你在描述使用“碰撞”这个词时也说了，它创造了一个更具戏剧性和生动的场景。创造那个生动的场景正是会被记住的东西。所以那些事后信息，陪审员可能在报纸上听到或读到的等等，这些信息正是会被回忆起来的内容，而不是他们最初的经历
or what they heard in the context of testimony. So it's quite problematic from the perspective of thinking about how investigations unfold because clearly witnesses to criminal activities, crimes are extraordinarily important in directing the investigation and leading to success, in closing an investigation. But I think that you have to understand, jurors have to understand, that their memories are susceptible, and that witnesses' memories are susceptible to these systematic errors. What is especially dangerous about this is that when people think back, they can't actually
或者他们在证词中听到的内容。所以从思考调查如何展开的角度来看，这是相当有问题的，因为显然，犯罪活动的目击者对于指导调查和取得成功、结束调查非常重要。但我认为你必须明白，陪审员必须明白，他们的记忆是脆弱的，证人的记忆也容易受到这些系统性错误的影响。特别危险的是，当人们回想时，他们实际上无法
tell which of those memories is real and which was made up. After some time, I can't distinguish between the things I actually remember and the things that I've reconstructed they both feel exactly the same. And I think you're hitting on one of the issues, right? You think that some memories that you have are, as you say, actually remembered, but they're all reconstructed. The question is, which reconstructed memories are more accurate? And can you learn to monitor that process? And I think people can.
分辨哪些记忆是真实的，哪些是编造的。过了一段时间，我无法区分我真正记得的事情和我重构的事情，它们感觉完全一样。我认为你触及了其中一个问题，对吧？你认为你拥有的一些记忆是，正如你所说，真正记得的，但它们都是重构的。问题是，哪些重构的记忆更准确？你能学会监控这个过程吗？我认为人们可以。
Coming up, we delve more deeply into Ayanah's research to understand the many ways our memories can fail us. I'm Shankar Vedantam and you're listening to Hidden Brain. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. The stories we tell ourselves about past events can also change the way we remember the past. Ayana once brought volunteers into the lab and asked them to imagine doing both ordinary things, like bouncing a ball, and bizarre things, like kissing a magnifying glass. I asked her why she did this and what she found. We were really interested in whether people could accurately distinguish between what they
接下来，我们将更深入地研究阿亚娜的研究，以了解我们的记忆可能让我们失望的多种方式。我是Shankar Vedantam，你正在收听Hidden Brain。这是Hidden Brain，我是Shankar Vedantam。我们对自己讲述的关于过去事件的故事也会改变我们记忆过去的方式。阿亚娜曾经把志愿者带进实验室，让他们想象做一些普通的事情，比如拍球，以及一些奇怪的事情，比如亲吻放大镜。我问她为什么要这样做以及她发现了什么。我们非常感兴趣的是人们能否准确区分他们
imagined versus what they actually did. And we compared performance on very simple, common kinds of activities that people would do in their daily lives, that they could easily think, of course I did that, as compared to things that they would easily think, of course I did that, as compared to things that they would never do. We had kissing and magnifying glasses and rubbing lotion on the chair. Very strange things that people generally would not do in their daily lives.
想象的事情与他们实际做的事情。我们比较了人们在日常生活中会做的非常简单、常见的活动表现，他们很容易认为“我当然做过那个”，与那些他们永远不会做的事情进行比较。我们有亲吻放大镜和在椅子上涂乳液。人们通常不会在日常生活中做的非常奇怪的事情。
And so they did some of these things and they imagined some of these things, but critically what we did was we brought them back in on a second session, and we just had them imagine a bunch of some of these activities over and over and over and over again. And what we found when we tested them two weeks later was that when people imagined these actions, whether they were sort of usual common kinds of actions like bouncing the ball or unusual actions, like kissing,
所以他们做了一些这些事情，也想象了一些这些事情，但关键的是，我们让他们在第二次会议中回来，我们只是让他们反复地想象其中一些活动。当我们在两周后测试他们时，我们发现当人们想象这些动作时，无论是像拍球这样通常常见的动作，还是像亲吻这样不寻常的动作，
the magnifying glass. It regardless of the bizarnas of the act, the more times people imagined it, the more likely they were to say that actually they performed it on that first day. So we were able to get people to believe that they did these strange things when they only imagined them repeatedly. And so, you can extrapolate and say, wow, can you get people to believe they've done very strange things in their lives that they would never have done? And I think the answer is yes, you can.
放大镜。无论行为多么怪异，人们想象它的次数越多，他们就越有可能说他们实际上在第一天就执行了它。所以我们能够让人们相信他们做了这些奇怪的事情，而他们只是反复想象了它们。所以，你可以推断并说，哇，你能让人们相信他们在生活中做过他们永远不会做的非常奇怪的事情吗？我认为答案是肯定的，你可以。
Now, you did find that people were less likely to remember doing the bizarre things than the ordinary things. So it was easier to say, I remember bouncing the ball the first time I came in, rather than I kissed the magnifying glass the first time I came in. But there were errors on both counts. Indeed. So it's easier to distort people's memories if the information is plausible. The more common, the more usual, the more easy it is for people to imagine themselves in this activity, and maybe pull from their prior experience to distort their memory. And so the more unusual, the less plausible something is, the less likely it is for people to come to believe that these events took place or that they engaged in some particular
现在，你确实发现人们不太可能记得做过奇怪的事情，而不是普通的事情。所以说“我记得我第一次来时拍了球”比“我第一次来时亲吻了放大镜”更容易。但两者都有错误。确实。所以如果信息是合理的，就更容易扭曲人们的记忆。越常见、越通常、人们越容易想象自己参与这项活动，也许就越容易从他们先前的经验中提取信息来扭曲他们的记忆。所以越不寻常、越不合理的事情，人们就越不可能相信这些事件发生过，或者他们参与了某种特定的
activity. So it's interesting when I think back to that childhood memory of my taking everyone's left slippers, one of the things that I realized my brain is doing is that in my mental image of that scene, I'm painting a picture of myself dressed in the clothes that I've seen myself wear in a childhood photograph. And of course, I have no idea whether I was wearing those clothes on the day that this particular event happened. And as you say, it might never have happened.
活动。所以当我回想起我拿走每个人左拖鞋的童年记忆时，这很有趣，我意识到我的大脑正在做的一件事是，在那个场景的心理图像中，我正在画一张自己穿着我在童年照片中看到自己穿的衣服的照片。当然，我不知道在那天发生这个特定事件时我是否穿着那些衣服。正如你所说，它可能从未发生过。
But it's interesting that I'm fleshing out things that actually I have no idea about using different elements of what I know about the past in a way to create essentially this picture that makes sense of a past event that I don't actually remember. And those pictures of our when we were children are highly suggestive of the way that we construct our childhood memories. I've seen myself in I think one or two outfits in pictures. And those are, that's pretty much how I imagine prior events. I must have been wearing this dress. Obviously, I had more than two dresses, or maybe I didn't, but I don't know. In fact, I remember very little
但有趣的是，我正在充实一些我实际上不知道的事情，使用我所知道的关于过去的不同元素，以一种基本上创造出这种画面，使我能够理解一个我实际上并不记得的过去事件。当我们还是孩子时，那些照片非常暗示我们构建童年记忆的方式。我在照片中看到过自己穿一两套衣服。而那些，基本上就是我想象过去事件的方式。我一定穿过这件裙子。显然，我当时不止两件裙子，或者也许我没有，但我不知道。事实上，我记得很少
from those, those early days. So yeah, we use our pictures, we use those stories. Your family has embellished and you stole all the left shoes. And those all serve to create a really fun story to tell, but maybe not an accurate depiction of what actually took place. of what actually took place. The fact that memory often is not an accurate depiction of what took place can help us understand how two people can have very different recollections of the same event. A warning that this next section includes a description of sexual assault. If you affirm that the testimony you're about to give before the committee will be the truth,
从那些早期的日子里。所以是的，我们使用我们的照片，我们使用那些故事。你的家人添油加醋说你偷了所有的左鞋。而这些都用来创造一个非常有趣的故事来讲述，但也许不是对实际发生事情的准确描述。记忆往往不是对实际发生事情的准确描述，这一事实可以帮助我们理解为什么两个人对同一事件会有非常不同的回忆。警告：下一部分包含性侵犯的描述。如果你确认你即将向委员会提供的证词将是真相，
the whole truth and nothing but the truth, so I'll help you, God. I do. Yeah. And one of the things I wanted to ask you is when you see stories breaking in the news that revolve around people's recollections of events, I'm wondering how you as a memory researcher process these stories. And the story that springs to mind is the one that occurred some time ago where Christine Blasie Ford accused now Supreme Court Justice Brett Kavanaugh of sexually assaulting her when they were both
全部真相，除了真相，上帝会帮助你。我确认。是的。我想问你的一件事是，当你看到新闻中围绕人们对事件的回忆而爆发的故事时，我想知道你作为一名记忆研究者是如何处理这些故事的。我想到的故事是前段时间发生的，当时克里斯汀·布莱西·福特指控现任最高法院大法官布雷特·卡瓦诺在他们都是
teenagers. I don't have all the answers and I don't remember as much as I would like to. But the details about that night that bring me here today are the ones I will never forget. She said she had a very vivid memory of this happening. Brett and Mark came into the bedroom and locked the door behind them. There was music playing in the bedroom. He said that it did not happen. It categorically and unequivocally denied the allegation against me by Dr. Ford. I never had any sexual or physical encounter of any kind with Dr. Ford. I never attended a gathering. And in some ways the country was divided over these dueling memories. What would you have
青少年时性侵犯了她。我没有所有的答案，我记得的也没有我希望的那么多。但关于那天晚上的细节，带我来到这里，是我永远不会忘记的。她说她对这件事的发生有非常生动的记忆。布雷特和马克走进卧室，锁上了门。卧室里放着音乐。他说这没有发生。他断然且明确地否认了福特博士对我的指控。我从未与福特博士有过任何形式的性或身体接触。我从未参加过聚会。在某种程度上，国家因这些相互矛盾的记忆而分裂。你会怎么说
said if you were on the expert witness stand about how to understand these two very different recollections about an event? Well, I think that it's important to note that both individuals could be recalling that night as accurately as they could. But the interpretation of saying that this couldn't have happened because I would have remembered it is an inappropriate interpretation of how memory works. Of course it could have happened, and you have forgotten it. Because often, we will remember things that are particularly salient to us.
如果你在专家证人席上，关于如何理解这两个关于同一事件的截然不同的回忆？好吧，我认为重要的是要注意，这两个人可能都在尽可能准确地回忆那天晚上。但是说“这不可能发生，因为我会记得”这种解释是对记忆运作方式的不恰当解释。当然，它可能发生过，而你已经忘记了。因为通常，我们会记住对我们特别突出的事情。
And so sometimes we forget things that maybe are really important to other people because they weren't that big of a deal to us. And so I use the analogy of my brother and I, my brother and I have lots of shared childhood memories, he's three years younger than me. And he will tell me stories that he remembers very well, and I have no recollection. And it's because it wasn't that big of a deal to me, but it was a big deal to him. And so I think the important thing in the Blassey Ford and Kavanaugh cases, they both, neither are necessarily relying about that past. It's just that memories are going to differentially degrade and differentially be distorted for
所以有时我们会忘记一些对其他人来说可能非常重要的事情，因为它们对我们来说并不是什么大不了的事。所以我用我和我弟弟的类比，我弟弟比我小三岁，我们有很多共同的童年记忆。他会告诉我他记得很清楚的故事，而我没有任何回忆。这是因为那对我来说不是什么大不了的事，但对他来说却是一件大事。所以我认为在布莱西·福特和卡瓦诺案件中，重要的是，他们两人都不一定是在撒谎。只是记忆会因
different individuals. Do I know who was accurate in that retelling? I don't. Could both have been distorted? Most definitely. What was interesting to me based on what you've told me for the last several minutes is that I think many of us believe that the more vividly we recall something, the more it must have happened.
不同的人而产生差异化的衰退和差异化的扭曲。我知道谁在复述中是准确的吗？我不知道。两者都可能被扭曲了吗？很有可能。基于你过去几分钟告诉我的内容，对我来说有趣的是，我认为我们许多人相信，我们回忆得越生动，它就越一定发生过。
And I think when a lot of people watch the disagreement unfold on national television, we said, well, she clearly believes it did happen, and he clearly believes it didn't happen. And only one of them, therefore, must be true, and the other one must be lying. Because if they both vividly recalled this, clearly they both would have remembered something as astonishing as this happening, or something as out of the ordinary as this happening. And in some ways, what you're suggesting is actually more difficult to stop up, which is that they both could have been telling the truth, or they both could in some ways have been making up something without actually realizing it. Exactly. You know, you hear these people say, oh, I believe this individual, or I believe this other individual. And the question's not about belief. both have their own versions of the truth. And what people have to understand is that there's no getting at exactly what happened
我认为当很多人在国家电视台上看到分歧展开时，我们说，好吧，她显然相信它发生了，而他显然相信它没有发生。因此，其中一个一定是真的，另一个一定是撒谎。因为如果他们都生动地回忆起这一点，显然他们都会记得像这样令人震惊的事情，或者像这样不寻常的事情发生。在某种程度上，你所暗示的实际上更难停止，那就是他们可能都在说实话，或者他们可能在某种程度上都在编造某些东西而没有真正意识到。完全正确。你知道，你听到这些人说，哦，我相信这个人，或者我相信那个人。问题不在于相信。两者都有他们自己的真相版本。人们必须明白的是，没有办法确切地知道发生了什么
a night, 30 years ago, 40 years ago. There's just no way to get at that information. Unless there was some video recording, we do not know. I always think back to, have you ever seen that movie, Rashomon? Yeah. I was thinking about it. I was thinking about it. I was thinking about it.
30年前，40年前。根本没有办法获得这些信息。除非有某种视频录像，否则我们不知道。我总是回想起，你看过那部电影《罗生门》吗？是的。我正在想它。我正在想它。我正在想它。
Rashomon's a great movie to think about from this context, because you have a retelling of an eyewitnessed event. And, you know, some of the witnesses to this crime have motivation to lie. But some don't. And they just tell a different version from their own perspective. And something, you know, this is really what's going on.
《罗生门》是一部从这个背景下思考的好电影，因为你有一个目击事件的复述。而且，你知道，这个犯罪的一些目击者有撒谎的动机。但有些没有。他们只是从他们自己的角度讲述了一个不同的版本。而且，你知道，这确实是正在发生的事情。
Generally, when we are telling about a past event, even if it's traumatic, we're telling it from our perspective, and that perspective alters our recollection. Just as we are sometimes too confident about our memories, Ayanna says there are other times when we're too insecure. When we jump to the conclusion our memories are failing us. Take for example the experience that many older people report in forgetting where they left their keys or where they parked their car.
通常，当我们讲述过去事件时，即使它是创伤性的，我们也是从我们的角度讲述的，而那个角度改变了我们的回忆。正如我们有时对我们的记忆过于自信一样，阿亚娜说还有其他时候我们过于不安全。当我们跳到结论认为我们的记忆正在让我们失望时。以许多老年人报告的忘记他们把钥匙放在哪里或把车停在哪里为例。
And I used to think that older adults actually are demonstrating more of these memory failures than their younger counterparts. And to some extent that's true. There is age-related decline in attention processes and memory encoding processes that likely result in these kinds of errors and will increase the frequency of these errors. But I also think that older adults are just more sensitive to these kinds of errors and are more likely to remember the error than their younger counterparts. Because many individuals, as they get older, become more sensitive to potential problems
我过去认为老年人实际上比年轻人表现出更多的记忆失败。在某种程度上这是真的。注意力过程和记忆编码过程存在与年龄相关的衰退，这很可能导致这些类型的错误，并会增加这些错误的频率。但我还认为，老年人对这些类型的错误更敏感，并且比年轻人更容易记住错误。因为许多人在变老时，对潜在的问题变得更敏感
with their cognition and their aging, whenever they have these kinds of failures, those failures are more salient, and so they remember them more. So I think there's also a bias in reporting, where there's under-reporting for younger people and over-reporting for older people. And you and others have also found that if you, in some ways, frame challenges as being about declining memory, you're more likely to see errors among older people in a phenomenon that sometimes call stereotype threat.
随着他们的认知和衰老，每当他们有这些类型的失败时，这些失败就更突出，所以他们记得更多。所以我认为报告中也存在偏见，年轻人报告不足，老年人报告过多。你和其他人也发现，如果你在某种程度上将挑战框架为关于记忆衰退，你更有可能在老年人中看到错误，这种现象有时被称为刻板印象威胁。
Right. And so, and I do this work in collaboration with my colleague Marie Mezzroil and we've been really interested in how when you either activate or alleviate threat in older adults, how that influences memory and other cognitive processes. And so what I mean by that is there is a negative stereotype associated with getting older and implicit in that negative stereotype is that you are going to demonstrate these cognitive deficits. And in fact, the majority of time I bring people into the lab that are, let's say over the age of 65, they're coming into the cognitive aging and memory lab. And the first thing they say to me or the researchers who are testing them as well, you
没错。我与同事玛丽·梅兹罗伊尔（Marie Mezzroil）合作开展这项研究，我们一直非常感兴趣的是，当你激活或减轻老年人的威胁感时，这会如何影响记忆和其他认知过程。我的意思是，社会对变老存在一种负面刻板印象，而这种刻板印象中隐含着一种观念，即你会表现出认知缺陷。事实上，大多数时候我带人进入实验室时，比如那些超过65岁的人，他们来到认知老化与记忆实验室，他们对我或测试他们的研究人员说的第一句话就是，你
know, I have a terrible memory or I'm really worried about my memory. They're already feeling threatened about their memory. And that psychological experience of just worrying about one's memory tends to negatively impact performance on memory tests. And so when you reduce that anxiety and you alleviate that threat older individuals do better. When we come back, how all of us can improve our ability to remember things. Because memory works in predictable ways, it turns out there are specific things you can do to make your own memory better.
知道，我的记忆力很差，或者我真的很担心我的记忆力。他们已经对自己的记忆力感到威胁了。而仅仅是担心记忆力这种心理体验，往往会对记忆测试的表现产生负面影响。因此，当你减少这种焦虑并减轻这种威胁时，老年人的表现会更好。稍后回来，我们将探讨我们所有人如何提高记忆能力。因为记忆以可预测的方式运作，事实证明，你可以采取一些具体措施来改善自己的记忆力。
I'm Shankar Vedantam and you're listening to Hidden Brain. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. What you're hearing is the voice of a man named Nelson Delis. He's what's known as a memory athlete. 5 of the states, eight of the states, seven of the clubs. Memory athletes memorize huge quantities of information, like strings of numbers, lists of words, and decks of cards. This is Nelson at a memory championship in 2014. I really love watching memory competitions and watching these memory athletes be able to rehearse back long strings of numbers
我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆（Shankar Vedantam），你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》（Hidden Brain）。这是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。你听到的是一个名叫尼尔森·戴利斯（Nelson Delis）的人的声音。他被称为记忆运动员。5个州，8个州，7个俱乐部。记忆运动员能记住海量的信息，比如数字串、单词列表和扑克牌。这是尼尔森在2014年记忆锦标赛上的表现。我真的很喜欢观看记忆比赛，看着这些记忆运动员能够背诵出长串的数字
and recite back long passages from books. They are just like us and we could do what they do and what they're doing is they're using memory like a skill that can be honed and perfected. So how do memory athletes imprint all this information in their minds? One of the most popular techniques is called a memory palace. You create a mental image of a familiar location like your house or the street where you grew up. Then you plan out a path through that space,
并背诵出书中的长篇段落。他们和我们一样，我们也能做到他们所做的事情，他们所做的是将记忆作为一种可以磨练和完善的技能来使用。那么，记忆运动员是如何将所有这些信息印在脑海中的呢？最流行的方法之一被称为“记忆宫殿”。你创建一个熟悉地点的心理图像，比如你的房子或你长大的街道。然后，你规划出一条穿过该空间的路径，
creating conspicuous stops along the way. Once you've done that, place all the items you want to remember at each of those stops. This mental image, the location, the path, the stops with the items on it, this becomes your memory palace. Here's an example. Let's say you want to remember four things on a list.
沿途设置显眼的停靠点。一旦完成，将所有你想记住的项目放在这些停靠点上。这个心理图像，即地点、路径、带有项目的停靠点，就成了你的记忆宫殿。举个例子。假设你想记住清单上的四件事。
First pick a location like your house. Now make a path with four stops along the way. You might start at the front door, then stop at your coat closet, followed by the kitchen, then the bedroom. Now go back and mentally place the four things you want to remember at each of those locations. Once you've done this, remembering your list gets easier. Just walk through your house in your mind and look at the four things along the path. The memory palace is based on the idea that to remember things that are unfamiliar, you
首先选择一个地点，比如你的房子。现在沿途设置四个停靠点。你可以从前门开始，然后在衣柜停一下，接着是厨房，最后是卧室。现在回去，在脑海中将你想记住的四件事分别放在这些位置。一旦你这样做了，记住你的清单就变得容易了。只需在脑海中走过你的房子，看看路径上的那四件事。记忆宫殿基于这样一个理念：为了记住不熟悉的事物，你
want to hook them onto things that are familiar. It's an ancient technique going back to Greek and Roman orators who often had to learn long speeches by heart. What individuals would be doing when they were giving speeches is they would associate elements of the speech to different individuals seated in the room. If people were sitting in the same place in specific rooms, they would be able to associate, let's say, the first line of the speech with a person sitting in the first row on the right and so on and so forth. And so all these speakers would have to do is look across the room to be able to
需要将它们与熟悉的事物挂钩。这是一种古老的技术，可以追溯到希腊和罗马的演说家，他们经常需要背诵长篇演讲。个人在发表演讲时，会将演讲的要素与坐在房间里的不同人联系起来。如果人们坐在特定房间的相同位置，他们就能将演讲的第一行与坐在右侧第一排的人联系起来，以此类推。因此，所有这些演讲者只需环顾房间，就能
remember the different elements of the speech. What's so fascinating about what you're saying, Ayanna, in some ways is that the very same processes that in some ways can contaminate memory, which is our past experiences, the things that we know well can contaminate the things that we learn, the things that happen to us because memory is reconstructed, you can actually use this now to actually improve your memory, you can actually use it to remember things that happen by associating them with other things in your past that you're familiar with. Yes, so we talked about how prior experience can distort memory, but prior experience can also scaffold memory, and we can use it to learn
记住演讲的不同要素。阿雅娜（Ayanna），你所说的非常引人入胜，在某种程度上，那些在某些方面会污染记忆的过程，即我们的过去经历，我们熟知的事物可能会污染我们所学的东西，发生在我们身上的事情，因为记忆是重构的，你现在实际上可以利用这一点来改善你的记忆，你可以利用它通过将发生的事情与你过去熟悉的其它事物联系起来来记住它们。是的，所以我们讨论了先前的经验如何扭曲记忆，但先前的经验也可以构建记忆，我们可以利用它来学习
new information. I'm wondering if I can give you a list of five things to try and remember and have you essentially put them on a familiar path and have you do this sort of live so we can see how this works. Would you be game to do that? We can try. I will maybe fail miserably. Well, we remember the stereotype threat research though, you shouldn't tell yourself that you
新信息。我想知道我是否可以给你列出五件事让你试着记住，并让你基本上把它们放在一条熟悉的路径上，让你现场做这件事，这样我们就能看到它是如何运作的。你愿意尝试吗？我们可以试试。我可能会惨败。好吧，但我们记得关于刻板印象威胁的研究，你不应该告诉自己你
want to fail miserably. Yes. Alright, so the five items I want you to try and remember are milk, eggs, olive oil, garlic, and pink cake frosting. So can you build a memory palace or one of these walks where you're familiar with where you place these five items that I can tell you them I can tell each of them to you as you go along the path so that you will remember them in the future again milk eggs olive oil garlic and pink cake frosting. Okay I will try. Do you want to try and tell us what you are doing in your head so that we
会惨败。是的。好吧，我想让你试着记住的五样东西是牛奶、鸡蛋、橄榄油、大蒜和粉色蛋糕糖霜。所以你能建立一个记忆宫殿或一条你熟悉的路径，把你这五样东西放进去吗？我可以随着你沿着路径走，把它们一一告诉你，这样你将来就能记住它们。再次重复：牛奶、鸡蛋、橄榄油、大蒜和粉色蛋糕糖霜。好的，我会试试。你想试着告诉我们你在脑子里做什么，这样我们
can follow along with you whatever the path is that you're setting up? Well for me actually I'm thinking about what I would cook with these elements. So I'm making all of these elements interact and you through a little curve ball in there with garlic, but fortunately garlic is a distinctive element in that list. Because I can make a cake with most of what you've, what you are already talking about. That helps. Because now the four elements that were potentially unassociated are now associated into one unit.
就能跟着你一起走，无论你设置的是什么路径？对我来说，我实际上是在思考我会用这些食材做什么菜。所以我让所有这些元素相互作用，你还在里面加了一个难题——大蒜，但幸运的是，大蒜是那个列表中独特的元素。因为我可以用你刚才提到的东西做蛋糕。这很有帮助。因为现在那四个原本可能不相关的元素，现在被关联成了一个整体。
So I've made something distinctive. Pink frosted garlic cake. Sounds terrible. It does sound terrible. But what's so interesting here in some ways is you're employing imagination to boost memory. And we talked earlier about how imagination can undermine memory. Isn't it fascinating that it can play these these dual roles? fascinating that it can play these dual roles. Yeah, our imaginations are highly effective in allowing us to remember these disparate pieces of information.
所以我做了一些独特的东西。粉色大蒜蛋糕。听起来很糟糕。确实听起来很糟糕。但这里有趣的是，你在运用想象力来增强记忆。我们之前讨论过想象力如何破坏记忆。它能扮演这两种角色，难道不令人着迷吗？确实令人着迷。是的，我们的想象力在让我们记住这些零散的信息方面非常有效。
And so it is associations that allow us to remember information. And when we are able to make associations, and when we're able to rely on interactive, unusual imagery, we're able to remember unrelated lists of items. So the analogy that's bringing to my mind is that to think of memories, individual memories are like islands, we consolidate those memories, but also potentially contaminate them by essentially building bridges to those islands from other islands that we are
所以正是关联让我们能够记住信息。当我们能够建立关联，并且能够依赖互动、不寻常的意象时，我们就能记住不相关的项目列表。我脑海中浮现的类比是，把记忆想象成一个个岛屿，我们巩固这些记忆，但也可能通过本质上在这些岛屿与我们
more familiar with. Some people talk about this as the difference between learning somebody's name is Baker and that someone's profession is Baker. If you ask that person to remember, do you remember the person's name or do you remember the person's profession, it's usually easier to remember the person's profession two weeks later than to remember that somebody had a name, a baker. Talk about this idea that in some ways the context that matters enormously in terms of what it is that we're remembering and something's just come with more context than others. I really like the analogy of thinking about memory as islands. We think about it as memories as nodes, right? So you have a particular
更熟悉的其它岛屿之间建立桥梁来污染它们。有些人谈论这与记住某人的名字是贝克（Baker）和某人的职业是面包师（Baker）之间的区别。如果你让那个人记住，你记得那个人的名字还是职业，通常两周后记住职业比记住某人叫贝克更容易。谈谈这个观点，即在某种程度上，语境对于我们记忆的内容至关重要，有些事情本身就比其它事情带有更多的语境。我真的很喜欢把记忆想象成岛屿的类比。我们把记忆看作节点，对吧？所以你有一个特定的
concept like Baker. And when I say Baker, a number of related concepts that are connected to those nodes are connected to those islands, those associated bridges that you're talking about are activated. So you think about bread and you think about maybe the time of day that you might go to the bakery. You think about your time in France, which I just got back from, so I'm not only thinking about France. And you think about all of these contextual elements that allow you to strengthen that memory representation. But those notes and those associations can also lead to error. IANA has also studied ways in which students can get better at retaining information.
概念，比如“贝克”。当我提到“贝克”时，许多与这些节点相连的相关概念就会被激活，那些你谈到的关联桥梁也会被激活。你会想到面包，想到你可能去面包店的时间。你会想到你在法国的时光，我刚从那里回来，所以我不仅在想法国。你会想到所有这些语境要素，它们让你能够加强那个记忆表征。但这些节点和关联也可能导致错误。阿雅娜还研究了学生可以如何更好地保留信息的方法。
One of the most effective methods, taking practice tests. Closing your books and forcing yourself to recall information turns out to be a powerful way to remember things you've learned. Another insight, space out learning and avoid trying to cram everything the last night before an exam. Also, try to get some sleep. Memory consolidation occurs during sleep and you have to have specific high quality sleep in order to consolidate these kinds of memories.
最有效的方法之一是进行练习测试。合上书本，强迫自己回忆信息，事实证明这是记住已学知识的有力方法。另一个见解是，分散学习，避免在考试前最后一晚试图死记硬背。此外，尽量保证睡眠。记忆巩固发生在睡眠期间，你必须有特定的高质量睡眠才能巩固这些类型的记忆。
It's interesting, I just read a recent article about sleep and consolidation and how during the context of sleep cycles, we actually select particularly salient memories and that gets preferential consolidation treatment while we're sleeping. And in some ways, there is an analogy here with physical activity as well, right? Physical, your trainers will tell you, yes, you know, try and come in more than once a week,
很有趣，我刚读了一篇关于睡眠和巩固的最新文章，文章提到在睡眠周期的背景下，我们实际上会选择特别显著的记忆，并在我们睡觉时给予优先巩固处理。在某种程度上，这与体育活动也有类比，对吧？体育，你的教练会告诉你，是的，你知道，尽量每周多来几次，
but they will also tell you if you try and do four hours of physical activity on one day, rather than, you know, half and come in more than once a week, but they will also tell you if you try and do four hours of physical activity on one day rather than you know half an hour every day You're not giving your body time to rest and actually build up strength and stamina and everything else It actually the rest is actually part of what makes the physical activity pay off Right So it's it seems that our body requires a balance in order to engage in the variety of interconnected processes that are going to result in physical change.
但他们也会告诉你，如果你试图在一天内进行四个小时的体育活动，而不是，你知道，每天半小时，你没有给身体时间休息并真正建立力量和耐力以及其它一切。事实上，休息本身就是让体育活动产生回报的一部分。没错，所以看起来我们的身体需要一种平衡，才能参与各种相互关联的过程，从而产生身体上的变化。
And a memory and memory formation is a physical change in the brain. And memory retrieval is the act of reconstructing some of those changes and bringing them back together to make a conscious experience of a recalled event. Alright so I am going to try and see if you remember that list of things and let's see if you can use your recipe technique Iana to remember the five items on that grocery list. Yeah I'll tell you I actually thought you were gonna ask me this pretty soon and so I mentally retrieved it right about the time we were talking. And I was like, do I have it?
而记忆和记忆形成是大脑中的一种物理变化。记忆检索是重构其中一些变化并将它们重新组合在一起，以产生对回忆事件的意识体验的行为。好吧，我要试着看看你是否记得那份清单，让我们看看你是否能用你的食谱技巧，阿雅娜，来记住那份购物清单上的五样东西。是的，我告诉你，我其实以为你很快就会问我这个问题，所以我大约在我们谈话的时候就在脑海中检索了它。我在想，我记住了吗？
I think I do. So is milk eggs, olive oil, garlic, and pink cake frosting. That's spectacular. And I'm sure in years to come, we will both remember the time that you made some delicious garlic cake for us both. I'm very happy with myself. Iana Thomas is a psychologist who studies memory. Why are recollections do not always reflect reality, how memories degrade, and what we can do to retain things better.
我想我记住了。是牛奶、鸡蛋、橄榄油、大蒜和粉色蛋糕糖霜。太棒了。我相信在未来的岁月里，我们都会记得你为我们俩制作美味大蒜蛋糕的那次经历。我对自己的表现很满意。阿雅娜·托马斯（Iana Thomas）是一位研究记忆的心理学家。为什么回忆并不总是反映现实，记忆如何退化，以及我们可以做些什么来更好地保留事物。
Iana thanks for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you. It was a pleasure. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Laura Quarelle, Kristen Wong, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Special thanks to Jonathan Burley and Jonas Harnow for their voice acting. Our unsung hero is Yap Mura, a theoretical neuropsychologist at the University of Amsterdam. Yap conducted a replication of the Herman Ebinghaus study from the 1800s.
阿雅娜，感谢你今天参加《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢。这是我的荣幸。《隐藏的大脑》由《隐藏的大脑》媒体制作。我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡（Bridget McCarthy）、劳拉·夸雷尔（Laura Quarelle）、克里斯汀·王（Kristen Wong）、瑞安·卡茨（Ryan Katz）、奥特姆·巴恩斯（Autumn Barnes）和安德鲁·查德威克（Andrew Chadwick）。塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行编辑。特别感谢乔纳森·伯利（Jonathan Burley）和乔纳斯·哈诺（Jonas Harnow）的配音。我们默默无闻的英雄是阿姆斯特丹大学的理论神经心理学家亚普·穆拉（Yap Mura）。亚普对19世纪赫尔曼·艾宾浩斯（Herman Ebinghaus）的研究进行了复现。
He generously shared his time to help us understand how the first study was run and his own research. Thank you, yeah. Next week in our YouTube.O series, the Emotion of Regret. We consider why regret isn't just about what happened in the past. It's also about where we're headed. Regret is actually a very hopeful emotion. It's something that is helping us learn from our mistakes and do better in the future. So it's actually, I think, a really positive thing to get to study. I'm Sean Carvedantham. See you next week. Thank you. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
他慷慨地分享了他的时间，帮助我们了解了最初的研究是如何进行的，以及他自己的研究。谢谢，亚普。下周在我们的YouTube系列节目中，我们将探讨“遗憾的情绪”。我们考虑为什么遗憾不仅仅是关于过去发生的事情。它也关乎我们未来的方向。遗憾实际上是一种非常有希望的情绪。它正在帮助我们从错误中学习，并在未来做得更好。所以我认为，研究它实际上是一件非常积极的事情。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。下周见。谢谢。你。目前还没有关于这一集的评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。